THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
SO BONTA THIS.
CHAU.
CHAVEZ.
GEN DAVID CHIU.
CHAUDHRY.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER YOU KNOW GARCIA.
ATWATER GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE MON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
WHERE SU CHI?
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES IT IS.
RUBIO.
SOLACE.
SANTIAGO.
THE STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TODAY.
POPE WELL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WORD.
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A CORPSMAN
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG MISTER FORM.
THE LATEST RIGHT.
LORD AS WE OPEN UP THE SESSION
TODAY WE DO SO RECOGNIZING THAT
APART FROM YOU WE CAN DO
NOTHING.
THEREFORE WE HUMBLY COME BEFORE
YOU ASKING FOR YOUR GUIDANCE
YOUR WISDOM AND COURAGE.
THE GUIDANCE YOU KNOW WHAT IS
TRUE THE WASN'T ACTIVE SOUND
JUDGMENT ENCOURAGED YOU WHAT IS
RIGHT.
MADE A LOT OF YOUR LOVE SO
RADIATE OUR HEARTS AND MINDS AS
THEY. THAT ALL MAY SEE THE
WONDERFUL WORKS OF THE MIGHTY
HAND PAYMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER FAR WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GRACE.
FEDERAL AGENTS TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC.
IT IS.
RIDLEY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
SOME THE GERMANS ARE CRIMINAL
THURSDAY FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE SUMMER
BETTER SEVEN A. M. THE AUDIBLE
ROCKY CHAVEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVEN SIX DISH PRESIDING SHE
FLIRTED ALSO LISTEN IF THAT'S
REALLY FOR HIM. MOVES RING
MINISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS.
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALDERON.
DALY O'DONNELL RO.
SHE EN.
CHOI.
AND MELINDA'S.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
BONTA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MAYES AND QUIRK.
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER MISTER SPEAKER FOR THE
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE. AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MEDINA PATTERSON MAYES
GRAYSON COOLEY AND DOLLY TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF GAS
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR MAIENSCHEIN.
MR MAIENSCHEIN FOR YOUR GUESTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM I'M
VERY PLEASED AND HONORED TO
INTRODUCE A FELLOW SAN DIEGO AND
AND AND.
CREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE LEADER IN
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY DOCTOR
STEPHEN KING'S MORE HE'S JOINED
BY DOCTOR DONALD KERNS AND
BARBARA RYAN OF RADIS CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL. DOCTOR KING'S MORE AS
THE PRESIDENT AND C. E. O. A
BRADY CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE FOR
GENOMIC GENOMIC MEDICINE
HERE RESEARCHERS WORK TOGETHER
TO IMPROVE THE LIVES AND
OUTCOMES OF FRAGILE INFANTS AND
CHILDREN. VIA THE RAPID POSITION
MEDICINE PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM
COMBINES RAPID WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING WITH EXPERT
PHENOTYPING BIOINFORMATICS DATA
ANALYSIS AND CLINICAL
INTERPRETATION TO DELIVER
PRECISE MOLECULAR DIAGNOSIS.
THAT'S ENABLING EARLY TARGETED
CARE IN ADDITION TO IMPROVING
THE KAREN OUTCOMES OF THESE
CHILDREN DR KING'S MARK HOLDS
THE WORLD RECORD FOR PERFORMING
THE FASTEST GENETIC SEQUENCING.
EVER
CONSIDER ONE OF THE TOP TEN
MEDICAL BREAKTHROUGHS OF ALL
TIME HIS WORK HAS BEEN FEATURED
IN NUMEROUS PUBLICATIONS AS
ACHIEVEMENTS HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED IN TIME MAGAZINE.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING DOCTOR STEPHEN KING'S
MARKETS COLLEAGUES FROM RATINGS
CHILDREN'S INSTEAD
.
AND DOCTOR ARAMBULA HAS GUESTS
WITH THAT STOCK ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
UP TO OUR LEFT WE HAVE THE KINGS
CANYON UNIFIED SPEECH AND DEBATE
TEAM IF YOU COULD PLEASE STAND.
THEY ARE JOINING US HERE TODAY
TO OBSERVE OUR WORK IN WILL BE
PARTICIPATING LATER ON IN A MOCK
DEBATE.
THEY ALSO HAVE REGIONALS NEXT
WEEK AND AS A FORMER DEBATER
MYSELF IN HIGH SCHOOL I WANTED
TO WISH YOU LUCK AND THANK YOU
FOR COMING TO OUR CAPITAL.
MEMBERS A SEE A FORMER MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE THE HONORABLE
PEDRO NAVA HAS JOINED US ON
FLOOR TODAY.
WELCOME SIR.
AND MURDER MS QUIRK SILVA I
BELIEVE YOUR GUESTS HAVE ARRIVED
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND YES
MY GUESTS ARE HERE AND THEY ARE
UP HERE TO THE RIGHT AND THEY
ARE FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT IN ORANGE COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT. WHICH IS
CELEBRATING THEIR TENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE GROUNDWATER
REPLENISHMENT SYSTEM.
THIS SYSTEM IS NOT ONLY
RECOGNIZED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
WE. AS A FORMER BOARD MEMBER OF
SANITATION I KNOW MANY OF THESE
HARD WORKING MEMBERS FOR BUT
TODAY WE HAVE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD MEMBER VINCENT SORRY MENTO
IN WHO IS A SANTA ANA
COUNCILMEMBER.
WE HAVE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT GENERAL MANAGER MIKE
MARKETS.
FROM THE SANITATION DISTRICT OF
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE DAVID CHIU
OFFER THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
STANTON WHICH IS ONE OF THE
CITIES I REPRESENT.
WE HAVE JOHN WEATHERS WHO'S
REPRESENTING URBANA IRVINE RANTS
DISTRICT.
AREAS THANK YOU AND I JUST WANNA
LET YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE
CELEBRATING THEIR TENTH
ANNIVERSARY. ANNIVERSARY OF THE
GROUNDWATER REPLENISHMENT SYSTEM
WHOSE DAILY PRODUCTION OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION GALLONS PER DAY
OF HIGH QUALITY WATER PROVIDES
ENOUGH DRINKING WATER FOR. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN
ORANGE COUNTY SANTA DATE
SANITATION DISTRICT OPEN THE
WORLD'S LARGEST.
IN DIRECT PORTABLE.
REFUSE FACILITY THAT TAKES
TREATED WATER AND PURIFY SAID.
THAT EXCEEDS STATE AND FEDERAL
DRINKING WATER NOW WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A BOTTLE IN OUR
DEATH HONORED YES I DON'T SEE IT
BUT I DO ENCOURAGE. ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TRY IT OUT THEY OCCUR.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW.
THAT AFTER THIS THAT WE'D LIKE
TO TAKE A PICTURE FROM ANY OF
OUR ORANGE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES WELCOME.
IN MISTER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON OF.
IN RECOGNIZING ARE FOLKS FROM
THE ORANGE COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT IN THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT.
THE GROUNDWATER REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM IS SOMETHING I'VE SEEN GO
FROM A PROPOSAL.
TO SOMETHING THAT IS RECOGNIZED
WORLDWIDE IN TERMS OF LEADING.
AND DEMONSTRATING TO FACILITIES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
THROUGHOUT THE GLOBE IN TERMS OF
WHAT CAN BE DONE. IN WATER
RECYCLING.
MAIN PART OF FACILITIES IN
FOUNTAIN VALLEY IN THE SEVENTY
SECOND AFTER AS WELL AS THE
SECONDARY FACILITY IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH IN THE SEVENTY FOURTH
DISTRICT AND I WELCOME THE
MEMBERS AND THE BOARD MEMBERS
AND THE STAFF. FROM THE ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AND THE
ORANGE COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT FOR THE GROUNDWATER
REPLENISHMENT SYSTEM THANK YOU
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAVEZ MEMBERS.
MEMBERS.
I HAVE GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TO
THE REAR.
I WOULD LIKE TO BRING ATTENTION
TO THEM.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
SENATOR GLORIA ROMERO.
AND FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER VAN
TRANH ARE HERE WITH MISTER
ROGERS AGAIN. AND MR GENE QUAN.
THERE ARE COLLABORATING ON THE
CALIFORNIA REFORM MODEL TRYING
TO SCHOOL PROJECT.
WHICH DEVELOPS CALIFORNIA MODEL
CHINESE SCHOOLS IN CHINA.
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME
TO SACRAMENTO
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
ITEMS ONE TWO THREE AND FOUR.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
MEMBERS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE H.
R. SIXTY NINE THE CORPORATE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTEEN ARE BY
SOME REMEMBER CAREER AND OTHERS
RELATIVES IMMIGRATION.
MS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES
I RISE TO REPRESENT TO PRESENT
TO YOU HOUSE RESOLUTION SIX
NINE.
A RESOLUTION CALLING ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO REVERSE HIS DECISION.
TO TERMINATE THE TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS DESIGNATION OF
SALVADORIAN IS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I ALSO IT ALSO URGES HIM TO WORK
WITH CONGRESS TO FIND A PATH TO
LEGAL STATUS FOR THE HARD
WORKING. AND DETERMINE
SALVADORAN POPULATION.
LESS THAN TEN DAYS AGO I CO LEAD
A LEGISLATION BY LEGISLATIVE
DELEGATION MISSION TOLL
SALVADOR.
WITH THE SPEAKER. AND MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FRESNO IN
CARSON.
WE MET WITH THE VARIETY OF LOCAL
SALVADORANS DIGNITARIES AND
SALVADORIAN PRESIDENT SOME OTHER
SCIENTISTS THAT AND.
WE WITNESSED A COUNTRY FACING
POLITICAL ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES BUT
ALSO. A PROUD PEOPLE FULL OF
HOPE FOR THE FUTURE.
DUE TO NATURAL DISASTERS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES BEYOND ANYONE'S
PERSONAL CONTROL. NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSANDTHS RECIPIENTS
FOUND REFUGE ON OUR SHORES.
AND IN OUR HOME AND THEN ARE
HOMELESS BECAUSE THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THE GOOD CHARACTER AND VALUES
GUIDING ALSO DORIAN'S HAVE ADDED
TO THE CHARACTER OF THE UNITED
STATES AND CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE MADE A LIVING. IN
MULTIPLE FEEL IMMORTAL FIELDS
HAVE CREATED SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT HOMES PAY BILLS PAID TAXES.
THEY RAISE FEW ES BORN CHILDREN
THAT ATTEND OUR SCHOOLS IN OUR
IN IN TRICKLE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ECONOMY.
THEY ARE A PART OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM AND HAVE.
AND HAVE EARNED THAT DREAM FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES.
THE PRESIDENT'S REVERSAL WILL
TEAR THAT CAME APART WITHIN THE
NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION TO
TERMINATE THEIR PROTECT US THAT
IT WAS NOT BASED ON ANY
CONDITIONS AND ALL SOLID OR.
THERE WAS NO NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN
A THOUGHT OR CIRCUMSTANCES AND
NO REASON TO RISK THEN TPS.
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES.
MUST BE THOUGHTFUL. AND
JUSTIFIED NOT BASED ON PREJUDICE
OR SWEEPING GENERALIZATIONS.
THE PRESIDENT'S RECENT TWEETS
UNFAIRLY STEREOTYPED SALVADORIAN
SAYS MS THIRTEEN GANG MEMBERS
AND DISPLAYED AN UNDIGNIFIED
THOUGHTLESS AND HEARTLESS
SUPPORT APPROACH. TO DIPLOMACY
THAT IS UNBECOMING OF THE
PRESIDENT OF OUR GREAT NATION.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE PRESIDENT
TO TAKE HIS OWN TRIP TO ALL
SALVADORAN ACTUALLY GET TO KNOW
THE COUNTRY. AND THE PEOPLE HE
IS DISPARAGING.
AS THE ONLY CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATOR OF SALVADORAN
HERITAGE IT IS MY DUTY TO SHINE
LIGHT. ON THE PRESIDENT'S
MISGUIDED STATEMENTS THAN
DECISIONS REGARDING EL SALVADOR.
SALVADORANS ARE NOT A DRAIN ARE
A DANGER TO OUR FOR OUR SOCIETY.
THE NUMBERS PROVE JUST THE
OPPOSITE WERE A KEY PART OF THE
WORK FORCE AND THE ECONOMY IN
FACT.
WHAT HARD WORK AND PASSION WE
CAN EVEN JOIN? THE RANKS OF
THESE PROCEDURES LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION ON TPS.
REVERSE REVERSES DECADES.
A BIPARTISAN FOREIGN POLICY
PRESIDENT.
IT. IF IT REMAINS UNCHANGED
THOUSANDS OF SALVADORANS WILL BE
TORN FROM THEIR HOMES. AND
FORCED INTO HIDING.
AND THAT WILL BE A DEVASTATING
BLOW TO THE PRINCIPLES OF
LIBERTY FREEDOM.
OF WHICH THIS COUNTRY STANDS
FOR.
I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE FOR
HR SIX NINE TO BOLSTER OUR
BELIEF IN MEANINGFUL. DOT FULL
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONSHIPS AS WELL
AS CALIFORNIA SUPPORT FOR
SALVADORAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
IN THEIR FIGHT FOR PERMANENT
RESIDENCY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MISTER
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I STAND HERE IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR.
A MAJOR SIXTY NINE.
MY DISTRICT HAS A LARGE
POPULATION. OF EL SALVADORIAN
IMMIGRANTS.
MANY THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BENEFITED GREATLY FROM THE TPS
PROGRAM.
I AM PROUD THAT WE'RE JOINED
TODAY IN THE GALLERY BY A NUMBER
OF CONSTITUENTS FROM MY
DISTRICT.
WHO ARE AFFECTED DIRECTLY BY
THIS ISSUE?
THE TPS PROGRAM WAS CREATED BY
CONGRESS TO PROTECT IMMIGRANTS
WHO COULD NOT SAFELY RETURNED TO
THEIR COUNTRIES.
DUE TO ARMED CONFLICTS.
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTERS OR OTHER
EXTRAORDINARY AND SOME TEMPORARY
CONDITIONS.
THE DECISION TO END THE TPS
PROGRAM LEAVES THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND DOUBT FOR THEIR FUTURE.
IF TPS IS NOT RENEWED MANY OF
THEM WOULD BE FORCED TO RETURN
TO EL SALVADOR.
A COUNTRY THEY HAVE NOT LIVED IN
FOUR DECADES.
I WON THAT ARE STILL
INCREASINGLY PLAGUED WITH SEVERE
VIOLENCE.
THIS ROUTE RESOLUTION CALLS ON
CONGRESS TO CREATE A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION. TO ESTABLISH A LONG
TERM SOLUTION FOR TBS RICK
RECIPIENTS.
THIS IS A STRONG BIPARTISAN
MEASURE WHAT I BELIEVE IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND I ASKED
YOU SUPPORT HR SIXTY NINE.
THANK GOODNESS LACKEY MISS
RETIREMENT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR SIXTY NINE.
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR HER AUTHORSHIP
IN LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
ARE CLEARLY THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN OUTSPOKEN IN HIS VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION AND THIS COMES AS NO
SURPRISE.
WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE'S BEEN
SIMILAR ATTEMPTS TO TURN BACK
REFER JEEZ FROM HAITI IN
NICARAGUA.
WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT MOST EL
SALVADORAN REFUGEES WERE
ESCAPING THE CONDITIONS.
OF THE COUNTRY AFTER THE END OF
A CIVIL WAR.
CONDITIONS THAT WERE CREATED IN
LARGE PART BY INVOLVEMENT FROM.
U. S. INFLUENCES.
AS A NATION.
WE HAVE A MORAL DUTY TO FIND A
SOLUTION FOR THOSE WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY ITS ACTIONS WE MUST.
CONSIDER THE PARENTS.
OF MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND U. S. BORN
CHILDREN WHOSE FAMILIES WOULD BE
RIPPED APART.
WE MUST FOLLOW THE WORDS.
OF OUR STATUE OF LIBERTY
TO GIVE ME YOUR TIRED YOUR POOR.
YOUR HUDDLED MASSES YEARNING TO
BREATHE FREE.
OUR STATUE OF LIBERTY SAYS
NOTHING ABOUT A TIME LIMIT ON
SAID REFUGEES.
TO REVOKE THEIR STATUS.
WOULD BE INCONSISTENT.
WITH THE TRADITIONS THAT WE HOLD
VALUABLE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
ON PRACTICAL GROUNDS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT REFUGEES WHO
CAN WHO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
ECONOMY FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
THEY'VE BEEN PAYING TAXES.
RAISING FAMILIES.
STARTING BUSINESSES.
AND CONTRIBUTE COLLECTIVELY SOME
THREE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
TO OUR ECONOMY.
THEY ALSO HELPED IMPROVE THEIR
NATIVE COUNTRIES TO DIE THEIR
CONTINUED CONSTITUTIONS.
OF THIS COUNTRY AND ALSO BELT AL
SALVADOR IS CRUEL AND
UNNECESSARY.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR CONGRESS TO
ACT.
NOT JUST FOR SALVADORANS BUT FOR
ALL OF THE TBS HOLDERS WHO ARE
PART OF THIS GREAT STATE AND
NATION. I RESPECTFULLY URGE AYE
VOTE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AND THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARDIO FOR INTRODUCING. AND
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP ON HR SIXTY
NINE.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF GOING TO EL
SALVADOR IT WITH THE SPEAKERS.
DELEGATION AND WAS JOINED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO.
BUT I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT IF
I COULD TO TELL YOU HOW OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES IS A
BEACON OF HOPE. FOR AN ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
FOR WHILE WE WERE THERE AND MET
WITH THEIR PRESIDENT THEIR VICE
PRESIDENT AND THEIR CONGRESS.
THEY LOOKED UP TO THE FACT THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY WE HAVE ELECTED.
SOMEONE WHO WAS BORN IN EL
SALVADOR.
AND THEY LOOKED TO YOU AS A
BEACON OF HOPE.
THE DELEGATION WAS A POWERFUL
EXPERIENCE FOR US IN LEARNING
AND UNDERSTANDING THE ISSUES
THAT PLAGUE EL SALVADOR. AND
CALIFORNIA'S TIES AND
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THIS NATION.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE THIRTY
FIRST.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
SALVADORIAN IS WHO LIVE IN MY
COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW.
MANY OF THEM WHO ARE IN
VULNERABLE POSITIONS WITH THE
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT TO TERMINATE
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
SIXTY NINE.
IT IS A SHAME.
THAT THE T. P. S. DESIGNATION IS
BEING TERMINATED.
IT IS A CLEAR SIGN TO OUR
SALVADORAN SISTERS AND BROTHERS
THAT THEY ARE NO LONGER SAFE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS AN INTENTIONAL DECISION TO
IN DANGER. AND DESTABILIZE THEIR
LIVES
AND RIP APART THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES.
WITH DEPORTING HARDWORKING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR SOCIETY RIGHT NOW.
WE AS CALIFORNIANS NEED TO LEAD
THE WAY. IN SUPPORTING THESE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
CALL ON THE PRESIDENT AND
CONGRESS TO DO THE SAME.
I ENCOURAGE MY FELLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES TODAY ON EACH ARE SIXTY
NINE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR HOUSE RESOLUTION
SIXTY NINE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FROM LOS ANGELES OF RINGING. OF
THIS FOR TODAY THE DECISION TO
END THE TP ASKED DESIGNATION
WELL SALVADOR.
IS NUMBER FORTY FIVE LATEST
ATTEMPT CHAIR.
MORE FAMILIES APART THIS
HUMANITARIAN PROGRAM.
HAS HELPED THOUSANDS ABOUT
SALVADORIAN SPINE ON SAFETY AND
SECURITY.
BUT NOW NUMBER FORTY FIVE IS
FORCING OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
TO RETURN. TO A COUNTRY THAT IS
NOT PREPARED TO RECEIVE THEM.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO AL
SALVADORIAN OWN PRESIDENT.
AND I'VE ASKED THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO RENEW THE
DESIGNATION.
THIS DECISION WOULD FORCE PEOPLE
LIKED VERONICA.
LIKE VERONICA.
NOW SEVEN DORIAN WHO WORK
OVERTIME AND DAY AND NIGHT TO
SUPPORT HER FAMILY OR CHILDREN.
TO LEAVE HER FAMILY CHILDREN
BEHIND.
TPS HAS BEEN RENEWED.
BY PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS
BECAUSE OF THE CONDITIONS AND
OUT SALVADOR REMAIN DIRE.
BUT WE MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
OUTSIDER DORIAN'S.
WITH THE TPS.
HOW CONTRIBUTE
SO MUCH TO OUR COUNTRY?
THEY HAVE GENERATED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT. THOUSANDS ARE
HOMEOWNERS.
MOST IMPORTANT.
THEY ARE PARENTS.
OF UNITED STATES.
CHILDREN CITIZENS OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THERE WE CALL OUR BROTHERS AND
OUR SISTERS.
IT BOUNCED SALVADORIAN.
WITH CPS ARE FORCED TO LEAVE
THIS COUNTRY.
THEIR HOME.
IT WILL BE DEVASTATING.
IT'S FAR MORE RESPONSIBILITY.
TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN AND
CALL UPON CONGRESS
WITH A LOUD RESOUNDING VOICE.
TO LET THEM KNOW THEY MUST
RENEW.
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE IT IS A
VITAL MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT ALL OF US WOULD AYE
BOAT.
SUPPORT OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AND SUPPORT HOUSE RESOLUTION
SIXTY NINE.
THEY'VE GIPSON MISTER HARPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER.
MEMBERS.
WE USE A LOT OF GOVERNMENT
JARGON HERE BUT IT'S TIME TO
BREAK IT DOWN.
I HEAR T. PST PST PST PS.
S. TPS MEAN.
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS.
TEMPORARY.
IS THERE NOTHING MORE PERMANENT
THAT A TEMPORARY GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM.
SERIOUSLY.
WHY IS THIS PRESENT SITUATION
BEEN CREATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE?
I LAMENT HOW MUCH WE SPEND.
OUR TIME TALKING ABOUT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ISSUES.
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T GET TO HAVE
ITS OWN IMMIGRATION POLICY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S GONNA
FIGURE IT OUT.
IF YOU WANT TO DECIDE
IMMIGRATION.
TIME TO RUN FOR CONGRESS THE
FILING PERIOD RIGHT NOW TO BE
ABLE TO SIDE WHAT TO RUN FOR.
BUT CALIFORNIA DOES NOT GET TO
HAVE ITS OWN IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THIS IS A NON BINDING
RESOLUTION.
I DON'T THINK IT'S WORTH OUR
TIME AND I WON'T BE VOTING YES.
MS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE IN SOLIDARITY WITH MY
SALVADORAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
IN SUPPORT OF HR SIXTY NINE.
AS AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THAT I SHARED THE
STRUGGLES THAT MY SALVADORAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HAVE.
WE ALL WORK HARD OUR
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE THE BY PRODUCTS
OF YEARS OF BLOOD SWEAT AND
TEARS EXPELLED BY OUR PARENTS
AND OUR ANCESTORS BEFORE US.
OUR MISSION IS TO PROVIDE THE
BEST OPPORTUNITIES TO OUR
FAMILIES SO THEY MEET LIVE I'D
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
WE FIGHT TOOTH AND NAIL SO WE
CAN PREVENT OUR CHILDREN FROM
HAVING TO NEW INDOOR THE SAME
HARDSHIPS WE ENTERED WHEN WE
WERE YOUNG.
AND WHETHER WE ARE ADAM ON THE
FIELD DURING OFFICE SETTINGS WE
POUR OUR HEARTS INTO OUR WORK
BECAUSE WE TAKE PRIDE. IN HAVING
AN EXCEPTIONAL WORK ETHIC.
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE AS
AMERICANS SHOULD STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR SALVADORAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I DON'T.
THEY USE REAL MISTER CHVEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES I LIKE TO STAND IN THE
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
AS I'M ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
MY SIDE OF THE AISLE SAID THIS
IS A TEMPORARY A PROGRAM. THE
FEDERAL LAW ON TEMPORARY
PROTECTION STATUS.
AND UNDER FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AND NATIONALIZATION ACT THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
MAY DESIGNATE A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
FOR TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
DUE TO CONDITIONS THE COUNTRY
THAT TEMPLATE PREVENT THE
COUNTRY NATIONALS FROM RETURNING
SAFELY HOME.
I PULLED UP ON MY IPHONE TODAY
REALLY WHAT THE THREAT LEVEL IS
IN THE HOUSE OUT OF PERMISSION
TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YOU GO TO THE DEPARTMENT STATE
AND PULL IT OUT YOURSELF THAT
SAYS. CONSIDERING TRAVELED
SALVADOR DUE TO CRIME IT IS A
LEVEL THREE.
THE SYSTEM THAT THEY LOOK AT THE
STATE IS GOES ONE THROUGH FOUR.
THE HIGHER THE NUMBER THE WORSE
CITY AS OF RIGHT NOW SAYS IT NOW
SALVADOR. VIOLENT CRIMES SUCH AS
MURDER A SONG RATE ARMED
ROBBERY.
IS COMMON.
GANG ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
EXTORTION VIOLENT STREET CRIME
IN THE CAR TAX AND ARMS
TRAFFICKING IS WIDESPREAD.
LOCAL POLICE MAY LACK THE
RESOURCE TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
TO SERIOUS CRIMINAL INCIDENTS
THIS IS ON OUR STATE WITNESS ON
A FEDERAL WEBSITE.
I UNDERSTAND WE DON'T MAKE
FEDERAL POLICY HERE IT'S LEFT
FOUR THE WASHINGTON DC.
BUT THIS IS A MESSAGE FROM
CALIFORNIA TO OUR LEGISLATORS.
BACK IN DC TOM WHAT WE THINK.
THEY MAKE CARE THEY MAY NOT
CARE.
BUT I THINK THIS BODY NEEDS TO
LOOK AT WHAT IS THE REALITIES
GOING ON IN THE WORLD.
AND CLEARLY.
THE THREAT THAT HAD DEL SALVADOR
BEFORE WHEN WE STARTED THIS HAS
NOT BEEN RESOLVED FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS.
SO I'D ASK US TO LOOK AT OUR
HUMANITY ON THIS ISSUE.
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
THEY WISH CHAVEZ.
THIS YEAR EDUARDO GARCIA YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM EAGLE ROCK.
SUPPORT OF HR SIXTY NINE.
AND ALTHOUGH WE JUST HEARD THE
GENTLEMAN FROM OCEANSIDE TALK
ABOUT HUMANITY.
WE'VE HEARD THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT SEPARATING FAMILIES.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE ECONOMY
I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS
JUST A BIT MORE. ON THAT
PARTICULAR COMPONENT YOU SEE IN
MY DISTRICT.
IT IS IMMIGRANTS OF MEXICAN
DESCENT AND SALVADORAN DESCENT
THAT CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY WHEN
IT COMES TO PEOPLE WORKING OUT
IN THE FIELDS.
AND TODAY MORE THAN EVER I THINK
THERE IS A HUGE.
RISK
THAT WE. ARE CONFRONTED WITH
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ECONOMIC
STABILITY. OF THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY DUE TO THE LACK OF.
CERTAINTY FOR MANY OF THE
WORKERS IN THIS PARTICULAR ARENA
YOU SEE.
WE HAVE AN INDUSTRY.
THAT IS IN JEOPARDY OF BEING
DESTABILIZE SIGNIFICANTLY
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF WORKERS.
AND BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
CERTAINTY WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION POLICIES BY OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE VERY PROUD AND EMBRACE WHAT
AGRICULTURAL DOES.
FOR OUR ECONOMIES HERE IN THIS
GREAT STATE.
BUT WITHOUT CERTAINTY OF LABOR
STABILITY.
THAT.
GENERATING REVENUE FOR THIS
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO
AGRICULTURE IS IS AT RISK.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND THE SERVICE
INDUSTRY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS A COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
POLICY THAT ADDRESSES THESE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED TODAY.
AND I THINK THAT WE AS
CALIFORNIA IS THE SIXTH LARGEST
ECONOMY THE WORLD. WE SHOULD
PLAY A BIGGER ROLE IN THAT
CONVERSATION IN WASHINGTON DC.
AND FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MENTIONED ALREADY THE.
HUMANITARIAN SIDE.
THE SEPARATION OF FAMILIES
OP BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE FOR US
TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER THE
ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS.
THAT THE UNCERTAINTY OF ANY
IMMIGRATION POLICY HAS ON A
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY SUPPORT HR SIXTY
NINE LASTED ALL OF THE SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CO.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MS CARILLO YOU MAY CLOSE
ON THE RESOLUTION.
I THINK YOU.
I THEN UNRECOGNIZED REFUGEE LF
DEL SALVADOR DURING ITS CIVIL
WAR.
I AM MOVED BEYOND WORDS BY THE
BIPARTISAN COMMENTARY IN SUPPORT
OF HR SIX NINE. THINK YOU.
IF INDEED IT IS THAT WE SAY IN
GOD WE TRUST.
THEN LET THE CALIFORNIA VALUES.
ECHO THROUGHOUT THIS CHAMBER OUR
STATE.
AND OUR NATION.
AND THAT WE DO NOT BELIEVE IN
TEARING FAMILIES APART AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE MISTER SPEAKER
I CALL FOR.
CO AUTHORS ON HR SIX NINE.
A RISK REAL THE FIRST ROLE WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. ON HR SIXTY NINE
CARPOOL OF IN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS HER COAUTHORS.
COOPER IS ON THE RESOLUTION.
IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY
TWO CO AUTHORS AND THEIR WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. WE HAVE GAS IN THE
CHAMBER. RELATIVE TO THIS
RESOLUTION MISS KOREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES WITH US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY ARE A GROUP OF TPS
HOLDERS AND ALLIES LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA AND ORIGINALLY FROM
AS THEM ALONE AND ON THE WITH US
THERE VICTOR DE US ALL BY YOU
LET ME KNOW MEDINA. HIDING
MARTINEZ PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING WELCOMING THEM TO OUR
STATE CAPITOL.
ENDEAVOR'S MISTER LACKEY ALSO
HAS GAS IN
CHAMBER TODAY.
YOU THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ALSO INCLUDED IN THAT
THAT GROUP IN THE GALLERY THERE
ARE SOME THE CONSTITUENTS. WHO
ARE PART OF THE SALAD GROUP
FROM?
?
SALVADORANS FROM THE OTTAWA
VALLEY.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR WORKING WITH
THIS GROUP IN A PROUD TO HAVE
THEM AS MEMBERS OF MY DISTRICT.
MANY OF THEM WALK UP VERY EARLY
THIS MORNING TO BE HERE.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE SOME
MEMBERS FROM THE BAY AREA THAT
ARE JOINED WITH THEM. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING WELCOMING
SALVA TO THE STATE CAPITOL
.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX ON ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING THIS IS.
AC ARE.
ONE SIXTY TO THE CORPORATE.
SO ME CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SIXTY TWO BISON REMEMBER LEVINE
RELATIVE TO RARE DISEASE DAY.
MISTER LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR ONE SIXTY
TWO. RECOGNIZES WEDNESDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH AS RARE
DISEASE DAY WE RECOGNIZE VERY
TWENTY EIGHTH IS RARE DISEASE
DAY. EVERY DAY AND THIS IS ON
BEHALF OF THE NEARLY SEVEN
THOUSAND DISEASES.
THAT A FACT AMERICANS ARE
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD AND I
AFFECTED ESSENTIALLY ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS
ACCORDING NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH.
THESE ARE NEARLY EIGHTY PERCENT
ARE ULTRA RARE MEANING THAT ONE
OUT OF FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
HAVE A RARE DISEASE BUT SINCE
OUR SEVEN THOUSAND RARE
DISEASES.
IT COULD AFFECT MANY PEOPLE THAT
YOU KNOW.
.
FURTHER THERE ARE MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED DRUGS AND BIOLOGICS TO
HELP THESE PEOPLE IN THESE ARE
REALLY DIFFICULT OF MEDICATIONS
TO DEVELOP BECAUSE THERE FOR
SUCH A SMALL. GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT SUFFER FROM THOSE DISEASES
IN NEED THAT TREATMENT.
PATIENTS CAREGIVERS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS RESEARCHERS A
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WORK VERY
HARD TO HELP THESE PEOPLE I.
LIVE WITH THOSE DISEASES BE ABLE
TO THRIVE BEYOND MAYBE A SHORTER
NUMBER OF YEARS OUR LIMITATIONS
THAT THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY LIVE
A GOOD LIFE AYE THAT WE ALL.
DESERVE I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE
ROLL UP FOR CO AUTHORS MISTER
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER LANE AND MISTER
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU TO MY.
COLLEAGUE FROM SANDRA FELL FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD AS
THAT CO CHAIR. OF THE RARE
DISEASE CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SIXTY TWO.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACTION LINK FOR RARE
DISEASES OR CAL RARE.
I ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO REPRESENTING THE
SEVENTY SEVENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FORMED THIS CAUCUS TO
PROMOTE PUBLIC. AND LEGISLATIVE
AWARENESS ON RARE DISEASES
MAKING CALIFORNIA ONLY THE
SECOND STATE.
TO FORM A LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ON
RARE DISEASES THERE ARE MORE
THAN SEVEN THOUSAND RARE
DISORDERS THAT TOGETHER. AFFECT
MORE THAN THIRTY MILLION
AMERICANS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR MANY BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS
WITH RARE DISEASES TO GET
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY CARE.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A LEADER ON
THIS IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUE SO
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THERE'S
pGUARANTEE PATIENTS HAVE A VOICE
IN SHAPING POLICY. AND ENGAGE
WITH THE RARE DISEASE COMMUNITY
ARE POLICY ISSUES THANK YOU
AGAIN TO MY COLLEAGUE TO BRING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE AS A MEMBER OF
THE REAR WHERE DISEASE CAUCUS.
AND THANK GOD THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM MARIN COUNTY.
WE DID GO ON A TOUR OF.
THAT LOOK THAT SOME OF THE NEW
INNOVATIONS IN RARE DISEASE.
.
AMAZING INNOVATIONS.
AND THERE'S A LOT OUT THERE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT'S EXCITING IS
THEY'RE ABLE TO IDENTIFY SOME OF
THE GENETIC OF ISSUES IN UTERO
OR EVEN UPON BIRTH AND THE
SOONER. THAT.
CHILDREN ARE GETTING TREATMENTS
THEY CAN ACTUALLY LIVE A FAIRLY
NORMAL LIFE SO THAT'S THE
BIGGEST FIGHT WE HAVE IS GETTING
THOSE NEW INNOVATIONS TO THE
PATIENTS. GETTING THAT ACCESS SO
WE CONTINUE THE FIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON ALL
DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED ON THE
RESOLUTION MR LEVINE.
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON ACR ONE SIXTY TWO THIS IS CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR
CO AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS SEVEN.
AND EIGHT.
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS THIS MOVES US TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
AND MR HOLDEN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT FOR US.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'D
LIKE TO ANNOUNCE TO THE MEMBERS
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WILL BE
HOLDING.
I'M INFORMATIONAL HEARING THIS
WEDNESDAY.
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH IT'LL BE
IN ROOM FORTY TO GO TWO AWARE
COURAGE YOU TO COME OUT WE ARE
DOING A. REVIEW OF THE STATE OF
BLACK CALIFORNIA THERE WAS PUT
FORTH BY. AT THE TIME SPEAKER
KAREN BASS
A WHILE SHE WAS SPEAKER AND THIS
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW SOME OF THE IMPORTANT
AREAS OF CONSIDERATION
ECONOMICS.
A HEALTH CARE. ENVIRONMENT.
EDUCATION AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
SO WE'LL HOPE THAT YOU'LL JOIN
THE CAUCUS AND BE A PART OF
THIS.
THIS THEORY THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN BEFORE
WE MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY A COUPLE OF OTHER.
BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
BECAME A GRANDFATHER ON FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH.
CHRIS GARDNER LAUREN DIANE IN
THE SOUTHERN LAWYER AND WELCOME.
WORLD A BEAUTIFUL BABY BOY
AIRING JUNIOR MCNALLY HE'S
POUNDS FOURTEEN OUNCES AND
TWENTY INCHES CONGRATULATIONS
MISTER. JONES SAWYER.
AND BRIEFLY MEMBERS A REMINDER
THAT ALL MEMBERS MUST FATHER
ANNUAL STATEMENT OF ECONOMIC
INTEREST FORMS.
BY THURSDAY MARCH FIRST.
PLEASE NOTE THAT FORM SEVEN
HUNDRED MUST BE SUBMITTED TO THE
CHIEF CLERK ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY SIX.
BY FIVE PM THIS DEADLINE IS FOR
MEMBERS DESIGNATED STAFF.
MUST FILE BY APRIL SECOND.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE.
MOVING TWO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PRIOR TO THAT I'M GOING
TO RECOGNIZE MISTER MAYES AND
DOCTOR QUIRK.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FROM
MY GAS MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER MAYES.
IT'S YOUR MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME IN THE BACK
OF CHAMBERS THE FAMILY OF CAROL
DELIA.
AND STAFF FROM LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
CAROL WAS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
AND TRAGICALLY LOST HER BATTLE
WITH CANCER. ON DECEMBER
SIXTEENTH.
TODAY BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE HONORING HER MEMORY.
CARE LEAVES A LEGACY OF TACKLING
SOME THE MOST COMPLICATED ISSUES
FACING THE STATE.
BUT OFTEN REALIZE IT'S NOT WHAT
YOU DO.
AND CAROL DID AMAZING WORK WITH
A SENSE OF PURPOSE AND PASSION.
AS A CURRENT COMMISSION OF
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION I'M
GRATEFUL TO HAVE KNOWN HER. IS
AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT
CAROL BE DEEPLY MESSED
PLEASE HELP ME GIVE A WARM
WELCOME TO CAROL'S FAMILY
MEMBERS I WOULD AGAIN ASKS THAT
YOU.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
DURING ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MR.
DALLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MEMBERS IS GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO MISTER VALLEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO SPEAK IN MEMORY.
OF THE REVEREND BILLY GRAHAM
BILLY GRAHAM WAS IN AMERICA WAS
AMERICA'S PASTOR HE WAS A MAN OF
CHRIST. WHO PROUDLY PRE SPREAD
THE GOSPEL IN PLAIN AND SIMPLE
LANGUAGE?
TO PACKED STADIUMS THROUGHOUT
OUR COUNTRY AND THE WORLD.
GRAMM WAS A FRIEND AND A
COUNSELOR TO AMERICAN PRESIDENTS
DATING BACK TO PRESIDENT LYNDON
B. JOHNSON.
HE WAS ALSO AN EARLY FOR IT AND
SUPPORTER OF DARK DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
IN A TIME WHERE SEGREGATION WAS
NOT THAT UNCOMMON IN THE SOUTH.
BILLY GRAHAM REFUSED TO SPEAK TO
SEGREGATED CONGREGATIONS AND
VOCALLY OPPOSED JIM CROW.
HE DIDN'T LIMIT HIS MESSAGE TO
CHRISTIANS AND AMERICA'S
AMERICANS THOUGH HE SPREAD THE
WORD OF CHRIST TO CALMNESS
RUSSIA IN THE EIGHTIES.
AND EVEN TOOK ISSUE SAY TO NORTH
KOREA IN THE NINETIES.
GRANDMA ALWAYS SAID MY HOMES
HAVE AND I'M JUST PASSING
THROUGH THIS WORLD.
I AM SAD THAT HIS TIME PASSING
THROUGH THIS WORLD IS DONE.
BUT IT GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE
TO KNOW HE IS FINALLY HOME.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON ON THE SAY I
AM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB MEMBERS BILLY. GRAHAM
AMERICA'S.
PASTOR.
DIED LAST WEDNESDAY AT NINETY
NINE YEARS OF AGE.
IN HIS HOME IN NORTH CAROLINA.
BILLY GRAHAM BEGAN HIS MINISTRY
AND NINETEEN FORTY FOUR.
BY SPEAKING AT RALLIES FOR YOUTH
FOR CHRIST THEM I OF CAMPUS LIFE
MINISTRY.
IN THE YEARS TO COME HIS
MEETINGS WOULD DRAW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. WHO YEARNED
TO HEAR ABOUT GOD'S LOVE?
HE SAID TO HAVE PREACHED TO MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
PEOPLE.
OVER THE SIX DECADES HE
MINISTERED AROUND THE WORLD HE
TOUCHED MILLIONS MORE.
THROUGH HIS TELEVISION AND RADIO
APPEARANCES.
BILLY GRAHAM EVEN JOINED US IN
FRESNO IN TWO THOUSAND AND ONE.
JUST WEEKS AFTER SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH IN ITS ATTACK.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE FROM
ACROSS THE CENTRAL VALLEY PACKED
INTO. BULLDOG STADIUM OVER A
FOUR DAY PERIOD TO HEAR GRAHAM'S
PLAIN SPOKEN SERMONS.
ESPECIALLY AT THAT TIME IN OUR
HISTORY.
AND I AND MY WIFE SHARON WE'RE
BLESSED TO HAVE BEEN THERE.
AND BLESSED TO HAVE BEEN BLESSED
BY HIM.
THERE WERE NO POLITICAL OR
RACIAL BOUNDARIES FOR BILLY
GRAHAM. HE WAS A SPIRITUAL
CONFIDENT TOO MANY INCLUDING
PRESIDENTS FROM HARRY TRUMAN TO
PRESIDENT. OBAMA.
USING THE WORD OF GOD. HE HELPED
GUIDE TO THESE LEADERS.
THROUGH SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT DECISIONS OF THEIR
LIVES.
AT SOME OF THE MOST TRYING
TIMES.
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
AND IT WAS THAT PUBLIC MINISTRY
THAT ENCOURAGED ALL OF US.
TO SEEK GOD'S WISDOM AND
GUIDANCE IN OUR OWN MOMENTS OF
TURMOIL AND DOUBT.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD ARE THANKFUL FOR HIS
MINISTRY.
FOR HIS DEDICATION TO SHARING
CHRIST'S MESSAGE WITH ANYONE.
AND EVERYONE.
DOES MILLIONS ARE JOINING WITH
US TODAY.
REMEMBERING A LIFE VERY WELL
LIVED.
AND WISHING HIM GOOD BYE.
WITH THE PORTION OF MATTHEW
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY THREE.
WELL DONE GOOD AND FAITHFUL
SERVANT.
ENTER THOU INTO THE JOY.
OF THY LORD.
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO JOIN MY VOICE WITH
LEADERS FROM AROUND THE WORLD
THE LIKES OF PRESIDENT BILL
CLINTON PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
QUEEN ELIZABETH AND RECOGNIZING
THE LIFE AND WORK OF EVANGELIST
BILLY GRAHAM AN ORDAINED
SOUTHERN BAPTIST MINISTER WHO
RECENTLY PASSED AWAY AT HIS
HOME.
IN HIS HOME STATE OF NORTH
CAROLINA.
EVANGELIST BILLY GRAHAM WAS
KNOWN FOR BEING A CONFIDANT AS
ALREADY STATED TO NUMEROUS
PRESIDENTS OF EVERY PARTY.
STRONGLY ADVOCATED FOR RACIAL
INTEGRATION JOINTLY PREACHING A
REVIVAL IN NEW YORK CITY WITH
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR.
EVENTUALLY BAILING OUT DOCTOR
KING.
WHEN HE WAS ARRESTED AT ONE OF
THE DEMONSTRATIONS HE WAS A PART
OF. HIS RENOWNED PASSION FOR HIS
FAITH PRECEDED HIM IN HIS
EFFORTS TO PREACH THE GOSPEL OF
JESUS CHRIST TO THE WHOLE WORLD.
THOUGH DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
EXIST THAT MANY ARE DEEPLY
DEEPLY PASSIONATE ABOUT THERE
ARE MANY MANY LIVES THAT WERE
POSITIVELY IMPACTED BY IS
MINISTRY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF REVEREND
BILLY GRAHAM.
YOU COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I RISE ALSO TODAY TO
HEAR REQUEST YOU JOURNEY MEMORY
OF DOCTOR GRAHAM. I HAVE TWO
SONS IN MINISTRY MILD LOSSES IS
NOW OUR SENIOR PASTOR.
ON I'VE SEEN THE IMPACT OF THE
GOSPEL IN MY LIFE AND MY
COMMUNITY.
I FIND IT REMARKABLE WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS HISTORY
THIS IS SUCH A NURSING TIME WE
FIND OURSELVES IN.
.
OF COURSE CHRYSLER AT THE TIME
OF THE GREAT PACKS ROMANO THAT
TIME IN HISTORY WITH SO MUCH OF
THE KNOWN WORLD WAS CONNECTED BY
ROMAN ROADS.
AND THAT ABILITY TO TAKE THE
NEWS OF.
NASCENT CHRISTIANITY ACROSS THE
KNOWN WORLD ON ROMAN ROADS
WASN'T UNUSUAL ASPECT OF THE
FOUNDING OF THE CHRISTIAN FAITH.
WE HAVE BECOME A GLOBAL. AN ERA
OF INTERCONNECTED GLOBAL
CONNECTIONS.
OF REVEREND GRAHAM AND HIS
MINISTRY WHAT TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE COMPANIES COUNTRIES.
AND YET NOW UNTIL RECENT EVENTS
WE HAVE SEEN OUR NATION AS A
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE FROM ALL
ACROSS THE WORLD SOUGHT TO COME
HERE.
WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE HEARD THAT
MESSES OF BILLY GRAHAM SHARED?
AND YET NOW JUST AS RESIDENTS
WE'VE JUST HEARD THERE'S THERE
HAS BEEN A MOVEMENT.
TO RESTRICT
THE CLOSING OF DOORS.
TO RESTRICT ACCESS TO THE
COMPANY TO OUR COUNTRY.
TO CREATE UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHAT
THIS NATION STANDS FOR.
OF.
REVEREND GRAHAM'S WORK.
CURRENTLY IN THE GLOW. WAS NO
DOUBT IT BUT WHAT MIGHT BE
CALLED THE PAX AMERICANA.
PERIOD OF DECADES
WHEN THEY WERE STABILITY IN THE
WORLD IN A FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT.
AND THIS.
THIS ERA. AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER WILL CONTINUE OR BE
RENEWED. HAS BEEN A TIME WHEN A
MAN LIKE REVEREND BILLY GRAHAM
COULD COME ON THE SCENE.
WITH THIS GREAT GIFT OF ORATORY
WITH THIS PREACHING MANNER. AND
TOUCH.
TWO HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO IS
SAID.
AND A HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
COUNTRIES.
AND.
I JUST THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
REFLECT UPON THIS.
ERA.
THAT WITH HIS DEATH ENDS.
AND THE DESIRE FOR PEOPLE TO
COME TO OURNATION IS SORT OF ON
THE BUBBLE. AND I JUST ASK
MYSELF WHAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
OF FOR THOSE WHO.
WHO?
HAVE APPRECIATE HIS MINISTRY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THING WAS COOLEY MISTER MAYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
TOO WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO THE
CHORUS.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LOOKED UP.
TO A BILLY GRAHAM AND I'M NO
EXCEPTION AS THE SUN. GRANDSON
AND GREAT GRANDSON OF PASTORS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW BILLY GRAHAM
WAS A GIANT FIGURE. IN MY HOME
AND IN MY LIFE.
ALTHOUGH I WAS NEVER ABLE TO
MEET HIM I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE BILLY GRAHAM SPEAK AT
LIBERTY UNIVERSITY.
AT THE COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHERE I
GRANDSON WILL.
I ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE AND PREACHED THE GOSPEL TO A
PACKED OUT CROWD. AT ONE OF HIS
FAMOUS CRUSADE THE ROSE BOWL IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR SOMETHING I
WILL NEVER FORGET.
GEORGE W. BUSH LABEL BILLY
GRAHAM AMERICA'S PASTOR.
AND HE WAS RIGHT.
HE SOUGHT TO BREAK DOWN BARRIERS
PHYSICALLY AND SPIRITUALLY TO
SPREAD A MESSAGE OF LOVE.
AND REDEMPTION.
THIS MESSAGE THAT HE PREACHED IS
SET TO REACH OVER TO HER MILLION
PEOPLE OVER THE COURSE OF HIS
LIFE.
YOU KNOW MANY CYNICS HAVE TRIED
TO REBRAND CHRISTIANITY AWAY.
FROM FAITH HOPE AND LOVE THAT
TRULY ROOTS US AND TRY TO TURN
IT INTO A POLITICAL DOCTRINE OF.
FEAR.
AND ANGER.
BUT NOT BILLY GRAHAM.
HE CONDUCTED HIMSELF IN A NON
PARTISAN WAY. HE KNEW HIS
CALLING HE STAYED IN HIS LANE
HE.
AND THAT LANE WAS THE PATH OF
LOVE.
HE PREACHED A SIMPLE GOSPEL.
THAT WE CAN HAVE ETERNAL LIFE
THROUGH FAITH. IN JESUS CHRIST.
WHILE THAT MAY SEEM LIKE A
SIMPLE MESSAGE HIS STYLE AND
HUMANITY MADE AN EXTRAORDINARY
IMPACT.
AND HE'S MISSED
ALREADY.
AS BILLY GRAHAM TOOK FROM THE
GREAT DEAL MOODY.
SOME DAY YOU WILL READ OR HEAR
THAT BILLY GRAHAM IS DEAD.
DON'T YOU BELIEVE A WORD OF IT.
I SHOULD BE MORE ALIVE THAN I AM
NOW.
ALL JUST TO CHANGE MY ADDRESS.
I LOVE GONE INTO THE PRESENCE OF
GOD.
BILLY GRAHAM.
WELL DONE THOU GOOD AND FAITHFUL
SERVANT.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR CHAIRMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF LIEU VANDER SO.
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIRST.
IN RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA.
LOU DEDICATED FIFTY ONE YEARS OF
HIS LIFE. AS AN EDUCATOR.
MOST OF THAT IN THE SERVICE TO
STUDENTS OF THE RIVERSIDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHERE HE SERVED AS ASSISTANT
PRINCIPAL OF JIM OUR JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL? VICE PRINCIPAL OF POLY
HIGH SCHOOL PRINCIPAL OF SIERRA
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL. AND
PRINCIPLE OF CENTRO MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
AND ALSO SERVED.
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND ON THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
ONE OF HIS PROUDEST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WAS THE NAMING
OF MARTIN LUTHER KING HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
DESPITE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO
CAME AND PROTESTS IT AGAINST THE
NAMING OF THE HIGH SCHOOL AFTER
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
HE SAID LIEU VENDORS BUILT SAID
THE ONE OF HIS GREATEST JOYS WAS
REMEMBERING THE TIMES THAT HE
SPOKE OUT IN INSTANCES.
WHEN IT WAS NOT PARTICULARLY
POPULAR BUT IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
HE WAS A MAN THAT HAD THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY WITH STUDENTS.
AND MADE A LASTING AND MANY
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN.
I WILL MISS LOU VANDER SO AND
RISE TO A DURING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO ADJOURN
SO WE GET ALL THE THE SNOW
FALLING OUTSIDE THE CHAMBER AT
THE MOMENT.
SEEING NO OTHER BUSINESS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
CHECK IN SESSION. THURSDAY MARCH
FIRST FIRST FLOOR SESSION.
AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CHIU MOVES AND DOCTOR
QUIRK SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH FIRST AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL THIS LIFTED